If you were trapped on a desolate island
with a bloodthirsty killer,
what would you do?
Someone is murdering all of your classmates,
and only you can find out who it is.
I'm here to break down the mistakes made.
What you should do
and how to beat Nana in talentless nana.
These students are about to be killed
one by one.
This green haired kid Nanao
is the most untalented kid in his class.
However, he's hiding a powerful secret.
His classroom was transported to an island
in the middle
of nowhere to train for humanity's
biggest threat.
These alien monsters showed up on the planet
around 50 years ago
and are now even able to hide among us
just waiting to strike.
These students have been sent to a desolate
island to train for their next attack.
The teacher announces that a transfer student
is set to arrive at any second.
That's when this pink haired girl,
Nana, shows up late, walking in
and introducing herself to the class.
She tells the students that her talent
is to read people's minds.
The teacher assigns her
to sit next to Nanao's desk.
He mentions that with all the students
present, they need to assign a class leader.
Nana puts her hands up and vouches for her
new desk neighbor to be given the position.
However, no one else agrees.
The potential leaders
decide to duke it out on the playground,
and the teacher gives them
permission to begin fighting.
They battle it out and throw it down,
but the long haired
pretty kid comes out victorious.
Furious, the skinhead throws
a gigantic fireball
his way, headed straight for the new girl.
But Nanao runs in front of her and blocks
the blast.
Admitting
that he does have a talent of his own.
Neutralizing other people's talents
All right.
These kids are supposedly training
for the incoming
apocalypse, where they'll supposedly fight
an evil known as the enemies of humanity.
This girl has been sent by the government
to stop the true enemies of humanity,
which the government thinks
is actually these kids.
But while this whole ordeal
is about to get messy as hell,
these kids should have been more suspicious
of what they were training for to begin with,
because no one has actually ever seen
an enemy of humanity,
which means that all of these kids
have just blindly been training
for something that this institution couldn't
even prove existed to begin with.
And this fact makes all these kids
gullible as hell.
And this is something that this little turd
will take advantage of
if these kids continue to be naive
as they've been.
But even Nana has exhibited
signs of this very trait
because proving someone is an enemy
by showing them a simple kill counter number
on a phone to signify their threat level
is some highly gullible B.S.
And this kill counter number,
it seems to be relying on nothing more
than purely theoretical speculation
rather than field grade analytics.
And this agency, they controls now
doesn't even seem to have any hard evidence
to back up
how they know these kids are capable
of what they say they are.
Basically, everyone stuck on
this island is as dumb as Wilson,
and we sure as crap aren't Tom
Hanks after school Nanao and Nana to meet up.
And he gives her more details
about his abilities.
He can disable users abilities.
However, he can't neutralize talent users
with psychic abilities.
The two then hold hands and Nana realizes
that she can no longer read minds.
Suddenly she pulls Nanao over the cliff site
He manages to grab a conveniently placed
hanging rope and looks at her shocked.
She tells him that the students
are the real enemies of humanity, and she'll
do anything in her power to kill them all.
OK, the only thing Nanao can do to survive
is to do a perfect feat.
First dove into the water and swim to shore.
Even that is risky
because the current could very well
pull or push him to the cliff face and then
suck him underwater and drown him anyways.
The drop from the top of the cliff edge
is about 180 feet, meaning Nanao is falling
from a height similar to Niagara Falls.
Cliff divers have successfully made jumps
from 100 plus feet before and survived
even higher jumps.
And there are also real life
examples of people
successfully surviving Niagara Falls
in order to maximize his chances
and before he loses his grip
and now must make sure he falls feet
first, cross his legs at the ankles
and clutch them together tightly.
The last thing he wants
will be to have a high velocity
sea water enema or have his legs dislocated
when forced into a full split.
By the impact of hitting the water,
he must cross one arm across the chest
and clutches elbow tightly to the chest
with the other hand, covering the mouth
and the nose tightly with the hand.
The sea is going to be cold, and by reflex,
he'll want to suck in a breath
when he gets dunked into cold water.
You do not want to suck in a breath
until you get back to the surface.
He's going to go deep.
He's got to sit tight until he quits falling
down. Once his momentum slows down,
he has to follow the bubbles
to get back up to the surface.
If it is too dark to see the bubbles,
he has to hold his breath
and drift up until he can see sunlight.
He doesn't want to be swimming
for the bottom, thinking he's headed for air
the next day. Nanao has gone missing
and no one knows what happened to him.
Nana has lunch with this kid who explains
his powers as being able to go back in time.
But then the other student who showed up,
along with Nana Kyouya here, interrupts
their conversation
to tell Nana that he saw her
and the now leaving school together
yesterday,
and she's been acting very suspicious Kyouya
then leaves the room and the time traveling
student urges her to come along
and try to find their missing classmate.
They visit the dorms and the student
goes back in time for a split second
he falls to the floor, drained,
but decides to try again.
This time he spots both her and Nanao
walking out of the school.
They change locations
and check out the cliff site.
The time traveler uses his talent again,
disappearing and reappearing in a flash.
This time, though, he mentions he made eye
contact with Nana's past self, forcing him
to return back to the present revealing
that this is one of his talents limitations.
That night,
Nana knocks on the Time Traveler's Door
and tells him that
he missed some vital information.
She brings him to the forest
and tells them that they
in fact were chased by an enemy of humanity.
And Nana was too scared to say
anything before and now was eaten alive
and she was forced to run away
Nana begs him to go back into the past
and change what happened.
But this girl is one
evil mofo and the time traveler
transports back only to drown in the past.
OK, this is crazy.
And now we know that Nana is up to no good.
Nana saw him use his power to punch skinhead,
but she didn't remember seeing the time
traveler himself
standing up and punching him.
Just the aftermath.
But the problem is, is that this time
traveler can travel through time,
but not space.
Because while you'd think
he would have traveled into the past
and appeared in the same spot
as he was standing it,
this was not the case in reality.
Because when the time traveler went back,
he mentioned seeing Nana walking with Nana,
and Nana's past memories were overwritten
to remember seeing him and which caused him
to zap back into the present.
And all this happened with him disappearing
and reappearing in the exact same position.
But during the final bit, where this time
traveler due to disappeared, he disappeared
above the lake and this was as clear
as day that he was standing above the lake.
Yet when he came back,
he somehow reappeared to below the lake,
which if we go with with what we saw
and how his powers worked from before,
it's strange and doesn't make sense
how he time traveled back,
but this time reappeared in a different spot
then the spot he was standing from before.
Now, it's possible that the topography
and spatial plane is something that Time
Traveler has to consciously account for
and something that is not a given within
his power skill set.
If this is the case, though,
then this could mean that
every time he jumped,
he would have had to picture from beforehand
where he would end up in relation
to where his body came from.
Something along the lines that Nightcrawler
would have had to do from before each jump
visually picture
where he would end up beforehand in order
to avoid the possibility
of teleporting right into a wall.
Also, we heard that time traveler's
abilities were affected after each time jump
and made him tired.
This could mean that after numerous time
jumps, his ability to plan
his spatial landing was affected,
and instead of landing
simply from where he left from
above the lake due to his extreme fatigue,
he could have missed, jumped and landed below
the lake itself, causing his death.
And while this theory is a little suspicious,
it's not suspicious enough that it couldn't
be plausible.
The fact, however, is is that
this kid should have taken
better precautionary measures
with a girl, that he was already suspicious
of to begin with.
This kid has the power to go back in time.
However, the main problem
with traveling backwards in time,
which at this point is
thought to be impossible due
to something
known as the grandfather paradox,
And comes from the idea
that if a person travels
to a time before their grandfather
or had children and killed that same person,
that act would make their very own birth
impossible to begin with.
But according to some physicists,
this problem can be avoided
by something called the
Novikov's self consistency principle,
which is a theory on paper at least,
that would allow for such a paradox
to happen,
meaning you could in fact go back in time
and be able to change the course of history.
But rather than alter
the present, you could simply create
another timeline that would never interfere
with the current timeline you just came from.
This is called
the many worlds interpretation,
meaning that there is a possibility
that the Time Traveler kid
in fact may never have been able
to alter the present
and may in fact exist in an entirely
different separate timeline in the past.
And the fact that the strongest
talented users so far on
the islands have evolved
out of traumatic experiences
makes me think
that he could have used his talent
one more time out of panic
since he couldn't swim,
he could have actually still been alive
and resided in an entirely separate timeline.
This is how insane this kid's powers were
and the fact that Nana tricked him
makes this guy an idiot.
And everyone in this school here
so dang gullible.
The next day, the students begin to wonder
where their two missing classmates have gone.
Nana follows Kyouya into the hallway
and he asks her to hang out.
They meet at his dorm room
and he brings her in to reveal
a massive collection of video games
and just before, when Nana wants to leave,
he tells her that he found Nanao's
watch Kill Joe brings her to the cliff site
and asks about where she was during her
first night on the island
Nanao has been missing since that date.
And no trace of him has been found until now.
He shows the broken watch and points
to the time being stuck around 6 p.m.
However,
Kyouya admits that she's too innocent
to be the one responsible for what happened.
The next day,
they visit their teacher to discuss
what they can do about the missing students,
and he tells them that there's no outside
communication.
Until the graduation date in the hallway,
Kyouya begins to notice
something is off about Nana.
He checks the storage room
outside to feed the cat, finding the place
empty and pours milk onto a pan.
He then turns on the stove
when suddenly it blows up into flames.
Nana finds his crispy body
outside and rushes to find help.
He grabs her leg before she can leave
and reveals his special ability.
He's invincible,
however, he has lost his sense of smell
because of this incredible power.
Wow, that's so unfair.
The next day Nana begins to realize
that people are getting suspicious.
Yeah.
You think this shy girl Michiru notices
a mark on her leg
and kneels down to liquor wounds?
She thanks her for the kind gesture.
However,
this shy girl isn't as nice as she seems.
Nana looks her up on her phone
and finds out that the girl's kill
potential reaches over 150,000 people
Nana find her outside
and reveals that her classmates
have set her up on a fake date.
They run off
and she thanks Nana for having her back.
That night, Nana opens her front door
to find Kyouya sitting outside.
He asks her if he can come in
but gets rejected instantly, finding it
strange that Nana was going somewhere late
at night after he hears a cry in the hallway
and runs to meet Hero's room, finding Nana
lying on the floor, wounded.
Michiru blames the attack
on the enemies of humanity
and the other students rush in
to see what's going on the next day.
Kyouya presses the subject. On last night's
incident.
Nana explains that she heard enemies coming
from Michiru, his room being invincible.
He questions why she didn't bring him along.
He also tells Nana
that the monster should have been too strong
for a small group of students
to make it run away.
Kyouya then begins to suspect the evil girl
even more.
And that's when Michiru suggests that Nana
becomes the new leader of their classroom.
OK, Nana is one sneaky mofo
and her inserting herself into becoming
the leader of the group
is one of the smartest things to do.
She'll essentially be spearheading
the operation and hunting down the enemies
of humanity while she simultaneously causes
all of this crap to happen to begin with.
But this means that Kyouya should have been
even more suspicious of Nana
because this is not the first time
that she's been found out at the crime scene.
And her power means that she is the only one
who can hear when trouble is nearby.
But up until now has
coincidentally been unable to hear any crime
until after it happens.
Interesting.
I mean, if it walks like a duck, talks
like a duck
and looks like a duck,
chances are it's probably a duck.
Nana, up until now has had way too
many coincidences with all of these deaths.
And while
they may seem random when put all together,
they make for a pretty compelling case.
This is why Kyouya should have investigated
further by spending more time with Nana,
because the one mistake he made up
until now has been to leave her alone
without figuring out what she is
truly capable of.
And I mean knowing your enemy is
the first step towards defeating your enemy.
Which is why
I would not only spend the day with Nana,
I would pester her every single day
to figure out just what exactly is her powers
what her limits are and her weaknesses.
Does it tire her out to read minds?
Once we figure out
her limitations will be better able
to piece together
if and what she could be able to do,
and which will give us a better chance
to figure out
and prove
that she is lying to us and everyone here.
Because the problem with Nana's powers,
unlike the fire guy's powers, for example,
is that her power doesn't involve
any perceivable change
within her surrounding environment,
which means that
for all we know,
she could simply be lying about her mind.
Powers, whom I mean, it could be real
because we can actually see if she's doing
what she's been saying she's been doing.
And that is a problem.
The entire classroom then agrees to let Nana
be the new leader of the group, but Kyouya
notices something is off.
Regarding the stab wound at home,
Kyouya begins to theorize
that the girl intentionally hurt herself,
knowing that Michiru would heal her wounds.
However, he can't seem to find a reason why
the girl would be trying
to kill his entire classroom.
Outside of the dorms.
This student approaches
Nana and tells her that he's discovered
something strange about the girl.
The student reveals
that he can see into the future and whips out
a photograph showing Nana killing him.
They sit down at the cafeteria
to sort out their problems and the future.
Seeing Kid explains that
whatever he sees in his future
photographs will happen with 100% accuracy.
Suddenly he brings out a photo of her
killing the now that night,
a future seeing kid blackmails her
into giving him a back massage
like a dirty bastard.
They sleep in the same room overnight
and he wakes up to another surprise.
From Nana.
He explains that during his sleep,
five photos will come from this camera
that will predict the future. However,
he's only got four in his possession.
He checks Nana's clothes to find a photo
showing Nana dead on the ground.
She freaks out
and the man makes a deal with her.
He's going to hide in the shed overnight
and see if the photo will come true.
OK, this is insane.
And what just happened proved that
Nana is more of a devious
little turd blossom than we thought.
However, this future seeing
kid should have known that someone
who had the guts to come to a superhero field
island and begin
killing people would have been
a little more cunning
than your average little bird.
The fact of that the matter is, is that this kid
knew who Nana really was when she first
came to the island and blackmailing her
into becoming his girlfriend was a bad move.
However, this kid's power is very passive
and limited in scope.
Therefore, he should have realized
that Nana would have used his camera
to play a trick on him.
I mean, it's
not that hard to put two and two together.
In fact, I'm more surprised that no one
has tried to pull that trick on him before.
Also,
already knowing the limitations of his powers
means that he should have thought
that someone could have potentially
shown him a fake picture of the future,
since clearly the photos that show the future
looks identical to any Polaroid photo shot,
which means that this was his weakness
and one he should have known to look out
for beforehand.
Also, Nana in the picture is shown to die
by ligature strangled which in reality
would have been a lot more difficult to do
and would have taken a lot longer to die,
which can take anywhere
from one to 15 minutes.
They should have, at the very least,
arised some suspicions within him,
because if someone was choosing
to kill someone by choking them,
they would have likely opted
to use their hands
or something more sturdy than a jumping rope.
Also, the one thing he had going for him
is that this picture
showed the exact location of where
the future incident was going to take place.
This meant he shouldn't have been so
willingly gone to the location to tempt fate.
As Albert Einstein once said, our distinction
between past, present and future is only
a stubbornly persistent illusion
because even if the future in theory
was already written
just like the grandfather paradox, the future
just like trying to change the past
would result in countless possible outcomes
as to how the future would unfold,
since the future hasn't happened yet,
meaning it can happen in one of many ways,
and this kid should have at least suspected
that his premonitions were possible
outcomes not absolute truths, as he claims.
In knowing this possibility,
this could have allowed the kid
to realize that he actually had
all of the time in the world
and should not have rushed to the shed
to begin with.
Rather, he should have opted to hide
in an entirely different spot,
like in a friend's room, in a place
that was closer to the main school
and its students that night.
The future scene
kid walks in and carelessly sits down,
not realizing that Nana is about to strike.
Suddenly she attacks him with the same weapon
from the photograph,
but the boy manages to fight her off.
He pushes her to the ground
and is ready to enjoy his victory.
But that's when Nana reveals
that she's pregnant with a poison needle.
When he grabbed her,
the boy falls to the ground
and she explains that the photo of her
dying was fate.
However, she still took one
of his five photos from the night before.
That's when the lights turn on to reveal
what the stolen photo really was
and then Michiru and Kyouya,
Walk in to find Nana caught red handed,
realizing that she's going to be found out.
She begs Michiru to fix the boy up ASAP.
She admits that the future seeing kid
was blackmailing her,
showing her embarrassing photos from the
future to pretend that they were going out.
She blames the boy's
current state on a medical condition
or from the invisible enemies of humanity.
A few hours later, Meet You two realizes that
her talent is beginning to make her tired.
She rubs his back
and finds a photo inside his shirt.
Suddenly Nana appears and questions
what she's looking at.
Michiru hands over the photo, wondering
what the hell she just saw.
Nana lies
and says that the boy's future predictions
only show what he's seeing in his dreams.
The next day
the class attends the boy's funeral.
The principal complains
about there being no police on the island,
and Kyouya interrupts to voice his suspicions.
He demands an autopsy
when suddenly the coffin begins shaking
and the boy comes back to life.
This short kid walks in and reveals
his talent is to be able to reanimate
two dead bodies.
He tells them
that the corpse will tell everyone
his cause of death if the body remembers OK.
Kyouya now has one of the most important
assets on this island, and that is this kid.
Because up until now, his gut has told him
who the real killer on this island is.
And despite conveniently looking innocent
and kind of dumb, Julia knows that Nana's
whereabouts during all the murders
are too much of a coincidence.
But what this guy needs,
just like in real life
court cases, is the evidence
that directly connects Nana's dirty hands.
With all the murders that have taken place
so far, however, it's odd that despite
the piles of bodies growing over the last
few days, that Kyouya hasn't already started
using the school's children to his advantage.
Because, remember,
we're at a super powered school,
which means that it's not out of this world
to assume
that the school is full of superpowered kids
and would likely have class records detailing
just exactly what their powers all are.
And Kyouya, clearly being all pally
with the teacher earlier,
means that he could have easily snuck in
and got some access
to get his hands
on those very important records.
This means that all this time,
instead of whining
and pouting about Nana being the killer,
he should have just started
looking into all the kids powers
that he could have better use to help him
find out the killer's identity.
If he did this from the start
and go in all lone wolf detective,
then he could have found out about this
necromancer kids abilities
from the very beginning.
Kyouya wants to get to the bottom of this,
but everyone here says that reviving
this corpse
is too disrespectful, and no one here
is about to let him shit on this corpse.
Kyouya then has no choice,
and his investigation into who killed
this kid ends right here that night.
Nana is in the short kid's room
while he sleeps,
and she sticks a needle into the boy's neck.
Injecting poison into his body.
She moves to his girlfriend's room
and gets ready to inject another needle
when suddenly the short kid attacks
and holds her down.
The girlfriend reveals
that she is the true necromancer
and that her boyfriend is actually already
dead.
Knowing that the girlfriend
is having relationship troubles,
she promises to tell what a short kid is
thinking if they let her up.
The girl obliges and Nana runs away.
She escapes the dorm
and rushes into the forest.
Necromancy Chick and her boyfriend
chase her down, looking around
and in the bushes for any sign of her.
Suddenly she pops out trying
to grab the girl's necklace,
but her boyfriend is about to attack her.
So she pushes the girlfriend over.
They chase her deeper into the forest and
Nana is suddenly ambushed by more corpses.
She runs into a broken shelter
and begins fixing it up.
But they find her
and she runs inside to block the door,
thinking she's safe and begins to set a trap.
But Necromancy Chick
already has a trap of her own asking,
Nana, didn't you check under the bed?
Suddenly three corpses jump out and attack
her, pinning her to the ground.
But fortunately, for her, the sun has risen,
freezing the corpses in their tracks.
Necromancy girlfriend here tells it
that the reanimated corpses can still move
as long as the light doesn't reach them.
Oh kay.
This twist is shockingly delicious,
but this chick could have been more careful
and methodical from the jump.
So far,
from what we've seen of this necromancer.
Unlike Nana, this chick lacks
a killing spirit, and this battle was uneven
from the start because despite her powers
and Nana seemingly lack of any powers
Nana seems to be the only one on this island
that truly possesses a murderer's mentality.
The necromancer take from the get go should
have, at the very least, been more guarded.
And if she couldn't
bring herself to kill Nana,
she should have incapacitated her
by breaking her legs or something,
because this lack of foresight
will come back to bite her.
Now, like most people, this necromancer chick
probably had some concept of time passing
and therefore should have used this
to her advantage.
Chasing Nana right before sunrise,
knowing that her powers stopped working
technically during the day meant
that she should have verbally stated to Nana
that she would give her a 12 hour head start
to leave the island before evacuating
the premises with all of her corpse friends.
All of this should have been done
before the sun rose.
This could have kept up the illusion
that her powers
had no limits in theory
and did not expire at sunrise.
The fact that this necromancy check willingly
admitted her weakness too was beyond doubt.
And the same thing with the future
singing kid.
These kids have been way too willing
to reveal the limitations of their powers.
Like Dang, what are you doing?
Stop doing that.
And did necromancy check locks a wounded
nana inside?
24 hours later, she comes back to the shelter
where Nana staying, finding
it completely empty.
She sends her corpses out to search for her
and heads back to the dorms.
But that's when Nana surprises them
and pushes them both over
and takes a slip of paper
from her back pocket.
She brings them to the cliffside
and threatens
to drop the piece of paper into the ocean.
If the item disappears, then the girlfriend
can no longer touch it to reanimate her.
Short's dead boyfriend.
Suddenly she poisoned the girl and drops
the piece of paper into the ocean.
Nana disposes of the bodies and then finds
mysterious bully in the forest.
She distracts the girl and poisons her
while she's not looking, telling her
that she'll provide the antidote
in exchange for the girl's phone.
She agrees and hands it over,
but Nana opens up her other hand,
revealing that there was never any medicine
allowing the girl to die on the ground.
The next day, Kyouya
questions her about the missing students.
She admits that they're all dead and brings
the class with her to see their corpses.
She blames the short kids
death on his girlfriend,
claiming
that she tripped off the cliff to her death.
She politely asks the skinheads
to burn the corpses along with the others
in the forest in order to give the dead
a sense of dignity and closure.
Yeah, right.
OK, I got a call bullcrap
on what Nana is saying.
Right now because this is so suspicious.
Up until now,
she has literally been coincidentally
unaccounted for during all of the murders
that have happened so far.
But the problem is, even
with all of the coincidences in the world,
unless we can directly link
Nana to all of this, we have nothing.
Because in a court of law, the presumption
of innocence is a legal principle.
That states
everyone is innocent until proven guilty.
And to top it off, Nana comes off
as so freaking cute and adorable to the point
that she is still our leader.
And this means that just like trying
to make someone look guilty
in front of a sympathetic jury,
this is going to be an uphill battle
because no one here is on our side to begin
with.
And the perception of Nana's character
means that everyone will find
any compelling coincidences or evidence
that we find against
Nana to be just hearsay at best,
unless we catch her directly in the act.
This means that we have two options. Really?
Well, either need to catch a Nana or whoever.
The real killer is dead
to rights in the middle of the next murder,
or we need to make it
so increasingly difficult
to the point to kill
were the effort to go through with any more
murders won't be worth
the amount of pressure we're putting on.
For the last part, I would say
now that even if we have no outside help
coming to the island,
we need to start taking proactive measures,
starting
with changing how this school operates.
Since we don't have anything on Nana,
I would focus more on scaring the crap
out of everyone and make everyone here
scared for their lives.
Because why the heck is everyone here?
So chill about all of these deaths?
Because just like Hitler's successful
fear mongering tactics in World War Two,
you need to grab everyone's attention first
in order to get them to do what you want.
According to evolutionary psychology,
humans have a strong impulse
to pay attention to danger
because of our inclination to survive
as a species
throughout our evolutionary history.
So we need to take a play
right out of Adolf Playbook
and use the concept of fear,
or more specifically, highlight
the threat of a murderer
being on campus to our advantage.
Scare the public, scare the students.
We'll be able to inform them
of the reality of the situation,
and from then on,
get them to do what we want, such as,
for starters, changing the rooms and areas
that people sleep and conversing.
If we can get everyone to sleep in the halls
where everybody is present
and accounted for,
this will be one method that we can use
to exponentially
make the killers next few steps
all the more difficult.
And this is just one tactic
that we need to start
using to slow all of these murders down.
From here on out, we'll be able to buy time
and figure out our next move
and or catch Nana.
I mean the murderer in the act itself.
Outside of the dorm rooms, Joshua leaves
the students with a simple realization.
Nana disappears
every time someone is murdered.
Suddenly they hear a scream
from inside the building and rushes
in to witness a deadly sight.
Another student is dead in her room.
They check her phone
and Kyouya blames the whole incident on Nana.
The other classmates then rush in
and demand him to explain what's going on.
Ethan says that Nana brutally killed
Poison Girl and left her friends contacts
spiked with poison, and in doing so,
she makes sure that teleportation girl
will never be able to find her friend.
He then explains that he already knew
that the girl has to eat raw animals
from the forest and finds it suspicious
that Nana was in the exact same location.
Kyouya then exposes her
for wanting to burn the corpses
and tells her the evidence speaks for itself.
She took the girl's phone
and texted her friend, informing her
that the contacts were going to be returned.
Kyouya then checks her clothes
but finds no evidence to prove her guilty.
He then demands to take care of the corpse
until morning
and agrees
to report the incident to the head office.
Later in the night, Michiru finds
Nana sitting outside of the dorm room.
Nana asks her what she's doing
and she responds by saying
that she's patrolling for enemies.
When suddenly Michiru
pulls a knife to her throat,
Nana pushes the knife away
and demands to know what's going on.
Michiru says she knows
she's a bloodthirsty killer
and it's only a matter of time
until she gets caught.
That's when their classmates interrupt
and material goes back inside.
The next day they meet up on the cliff side
and not a confront her
about being a fake Michiru.
The girl admits that she isn't the original
and reveals himself as the ex student Jin.
He explains that he's here to make a deal
and takes her back to his hideout.
The ex-students makes them drinks
and explains that he's been on the island
for five years since all of his classmates
killed each other.
He says that he managed to escape the island
with his ability
to shapeshift into any living being
and flew off the island.
However, his own grandmother
refused to believe that he was alive.
He then returned to the island
to find a safe haven
and figure out the secrets
behind this deadly school.
Suddenly, the students begins coughing
and now reveals that his drink was poisoned.
She picks up her phone
to call the higher ups.
But then a fake version, Cheol
snatches it from behind.
She tries to run, but Jin
then turns into skinhead and uses his ability
to summon up a giant fireball badly
injuring her.
Jin questions her background
and she explains that her family was killed
by the enemies of humanity.
The next day, the classmates
attend the funeral of another student
Kyouya asks the principal
to speak with the higher ups, realizing
the situation is becoming more
and more suspicious.
He then finds both Nana and Michiru
hanging out in the morning
demanding that they follow him somewhere.
He then reveals another deadly murder.
However, Nana realizes
that it wasn't her doing and the dead guy's
green haired girlfriend admits
that she was the one who found the body.
The girlfriend brings
everyone outside and uses her ability.
Unclear.
That night,
the principal knocks on Nana's door later
in the night
to hand over her missing uniform.
She thanks him and realizes
that the poison vial hidden inside is gone.
She, Kyouya, interrupts to say that he's
going to be interrogating the girlfriend.
That's when the principal mentions
that the higher ups from the mainland
will soon
be visiting him, and Nana
questioned the girlfriend on the incident.
They then discuss
what was said in the hallway,
and Kyouya determines her to be the killer.
He suspects that the couple
had a fight beforehand
and that the girl went crazy, killing him
and using her ability
to cover up any evidence.
All right, if I'm clear, this event
will only make our jobs that much harder,
because now what we have here
is to lose threads in a very messy web
of conflicting lies.
This girl has the ability
to basically control
and manipulate the pressure out of air.
She can also create lethal air blades that,
as we saw, you wouldn't want to mess with.
She's basically like a little discount
air better, like egg or ong
if you mess with them. Night
Shyamalan's Airbender version.
I pity you if that's the case.
But regardless, something is off here
because the body was found
by the green haired
girlfriend in the morning,
but the corpse has clearly been here
for a few hours,
meaning this poor little dude died at night.
But if this is the case again, we got to ask
why did the group of boys next door
didn't hear anything?
Now there is a very obvious possibility
that they could all be in on it,
but this seems unlikely.
And judging from their character
and demeanor, I doubt this.
Now, even though this isn't
considered a superhuman ability,
it might as well be because on average
human screams can be loud as hell.
Going near is 100 decibels in volume.
And for comparison,
the sound of a whisper is around 30 decibels.
A normal conversation is 60 decibels
and a motorcycle running about
is about 95 decibels.
And depending on the wall, a conversation of
about 40 decibels will be able to be heard.
The average wall
thickness in Japan is about 9.8 inches thick,
which would be considered quite
then in something in comparison
to the average
wall thickness of a skyscraper
over in the West, such as in Australia,
where the thickness of their walls
tend to be around 19 inches.
But in general the make up of interior walls
will feature several layers of wall types
and thicknesses
which will consist of sheathing siding,
wall boards and finishes including air gaps
and so on.
This means that the wall thickness
for different structures
will vary between residential walls
and the rest.
However, it seems as though
this school walls is made of much heavier
construction materials such as concrete,
which will usually be around
eight to 12 inches thick.
And also from the fact
that this school is on an island
where the weather could be more rough
leads me to believe
that concrete blocks
were the foundation of the walls.
And this material is naturally resistant
to extreme temperatures and has increased
thermal insulation properties
and it will not degrade as a result of ice
and thaw, making it a reliable material
and one that will be able to isolate sound
very well.
The concrete walls here
would have likely been able to absorb
some of the energy that would have come
from the boyfriend screen.
However, such a screen
produced from the boyfriend at around
90 decibels
would have still been able to be heard
at least somewhat by the group next door.
If we take into account
that the entrance of the room
featured a wooden door
because a standard wooden door
tends to only offer around
20 decibels of soundproofing at around 1.4
inches of width between one side of the door
and the other. In short,
it means it's impossible
that the boys wouldn't
have heard any type of scream.
Also, someone entering
a room would have likely made
the victim inside the room
turn around to see who's coming in,
because that's what people do
when someone enters a room.
But if the victim didn't
recognize the killer,
obviously he would have
either used his power screams
or there would have been a noisy commotion
of some kind that would have been heard
through the walls and the door,
at least a little bit.
The fact that the victim didn't scream
and had his back turned here
suggests that the victim knew the killer
and let the killer in before the murderer
literally back stabbed him.
This makes the girlfriend super suspicious
as hell as she would have been
a very familiar face
and could have killed the boyfriend
after he let her in when he wasn't
looking for the fact that the body, due
to rigor mortis
setting in after postmortem, could indicate
that the crime scene happened elsewhere,
meaning this kid was killed somewhere else
and brought in here afterwards,
which could have also explained
why no one heard the screams to begin with.
And if that's the case,
this still would have made the girlfriend
my primary suspect
and not nana, at least in this case.
If I'm Kyouya then the one thing I would
start working on is the motive behind it.
And this will likely explain the reasoning
which will either make the girlfriend
to look more guilty or more innocent,
which could benefit us
by narrowing down the suspect list.
Either way, the motive behind the girlfriend
is the one thing I would begin focusing on,
and this will help inform everything else
later Jin finds her
looking through mysterious diary.
He hands over a poison vial
that she left behind
and tells it that who has been in the shower
for far too long she goes into the bathroom
and sees her passed out in the tub.
She then takes the exhausted girl to bed
and notices
that she's suffering from a strange illness.
She then brings Kyouya to help
but he can't seem to find out what's wrong.
Later, the girlfriend visits
and asks her how Michiru got injured.
That's when Nana realizes
that something is clearly off.
That night, Jin visits to inform her that he
spotted Michiru walking out extremely late.
He then mentions that the girl said
she was called to by somebody
but doesn't know who
Nana chases after her missing friend
and finds her injured in the forest.
She then jumps in front of the unknown
killers attack, severely injuring herself.
And that's
when Nana realizes that she knows exactly
who the culprit is. One of the students
that has the talent
to leave his physical body
and kill that student.
She turns around to find out
that the killer is the blond kid.
Kentaro He then stabs Nana one more time
and she begs Michiru to stay away.
And just when all hope is lost,
the ghost version of himself begins
to lose consciousness as Kyouya chokes him
in the bathroom stall.
Stopping him from attacking.
However, Nana is fatally wounded
with only minutes before death.
That's when Michiru comes back
and begins to heal the injured Nana.
Nana wakes up with her life saved,
but she looks over to see that her friend
is dead, meaning that she can now mark off
another kill off of her kill list.